c'est moi s'il enquête au centre vous
emmène en chine à la découverte des
liens historiques qui unissent l'empiré
du milieu à la ville de montargis il ya
un siècle des étudiants qui allaient
devenir les futurs dirigeants chinois
sont venus dans le loiret pour découvrir
la culture française
aujourd'hui les échanges se poursuivent
chaque année des jeunes du montargois
font le voyage en sens inverse
dans ce numéro nous découvrirons aussi
le nouvel hôpital d'orléans énorme
chantier en cours d'achèvement dans
l'hôpital du 21e siècle les robots n'ont
pas pris la place des médecins mais ils
effectuent de plus en plus de tâches et
puis nous irons la rencontre des seniors
utiles ces retraités qui part en ville
ou par nécessité continuent à mener une
vie active
lang est au centre c'est désormais le
mercredi prochain rendez vous mercredi
16 septembre à 23h20 sur france 3 centre
val de loire